right let's start with you obviously
we've got to deal with the details on
the ground and then the potential
consequences you're the Russia expert
the consequences for Russia perhaps
going forward yeah you know unclear at
this point I mean interestingly your
detector mentioned the re-election of
step ladder or coronation as he put it
expected for Friday so just a couple of
days ago two US senators wrote the
delegates the 209 that will be voting
saying encouraging them not to reelect
Sepp Blatter because he has been such a
staunch supporter of Russia as a host of
the 2018 games and just as recently as
April he met President Putin sep ladder
and said any of these politicians that
are calling for Russia to not host the
the world cup in 2018 should just stay
home instead of make these calls if they
if they don't want to come I mean
interestingly the conversation about
Russia thus far has been focused on
Russia's role in Ukraine and that would
be why Russia shouldn't host the 2018
world cup and then the other part has
been the sanctions that this would give
Russia kind of an economic lifeline just
as the sanctions have been there and
there has been some criticism Russia of
rush on ethics grounds it was really you
know sort of the uproar began when
Russia was selected but it's been pretty
buted so unclear what this is going to
mean for rush I mean you did hear the
point they are made that it seems
unlikely that FIFA would want to change
course at this point in time well just
go back to the core of the issue of
course there's a presidential election
and in many ways things haven't changed
it's just the volume it's been turned up
radically my due date amex I looks back
to nineteen ninety-eight when set
Blatter first won an election and even
back then there were allegations of
vote-buying cash to Africa delegates
never proved never start we are five
elections on 2015 it's set Blatter vs
prince ali bin al hussein of jordan king
abdullah's brother the son of the late
King Hussein nobody gives him a chance
but does it change
things now Blatter has been celebrated
for what he's done to FIFA's finances
forget what the reputational damage has
taken place since you took over in 1998
because there's been a whole load of
scandals I could sit here for an hour
and tell you about the scandals but
investors and FIFA members of which
there are 209 all of which will be
present in FIFA all of which will be
present in Zurich they look at the
finances and since Blatter took over in
1998 the finances have blossomed the
World Cup is a money generating machine
revenues from four years before the
brazil world cup through the world cup
5.8 billion dollars every single member
association gets a 250 thousand pound
annual grant on top of a five hundred
thousand dollar bonus that's the issue
old Cup that's kind of the issue mark
and money talks as you say and over the
last 12 months the big issue has been
sponsorship yes and how have a large who
preceded set Blatter he taught Blatter
the way of winning elections which was
don't focus on the Brazil's don't focus
on the Germany's focus on the Cayman
Islands focus on Montserrat which has
got tens of thousands of inhabitants
their vote is equal to the likes of
Brazil so if you focus on Africa if you
focus on the Caribbean it's far more
worthwhile for your cause in trying to
be reacted then focusing on England
which of course dislikes platter or UEFA
under yester platen II who's completely
vocal in his criticism of set platter
and FIFA and it's interesting because I
think you'll hear the you know the
Russians in the next couple of days say
this is just spilt milk you know on the
behalf of the Americans because they
lost out to Qatar for the 2022 World Cup
I mean the US was one of the luxuries
that lost out to cats right when it was
down to the two yeah in the final vote
and you know Bill Clinton went there was
really high profile sort of campaign to
win the world cup in 2022 and it didn't
go anywhere and and what you know you'll
hear the Russians and a lot of
the other naysayer say is well actually
this is just the United States unhappy
with that decision using its legal power
and its global policing capability to
try and undo that why don't we just come
just all this process is just on the
sponsors that there are six main
sponsors coca-cola's one of them visa is
one of them as well now visa recently
has come out and said it's gravely
concerned about how migrant workers had
been treated in the building of stadiums
for the cata 2022 World Cup added as has
stated similar concerns after the
awarding of the world cups in 2018 to
Russia and 2022 to had it at a 2022 to
cater but these are very lucrative these
tournaments for FIFA and they do benefit
the sponsors and that's why they're
being under fire to say more will we
hear more from the likes of coca-cola
today will we hear more from the likes
of visa will we hear more from the likes
of added a switch relies solely on its
football since the 1970s for its success